hey what's going on it's Bill bur it's
time for the Thursday afternoon just
before Friday Monday Morning podcast and
I'm just checking
in on you woo woo woo oh yeah oh Billy
freckles is out on the road
here getting ready to do Madison Square
Garden um where the hell am I am in
Atlanta hotlanta as the kids call it par
City whatever the [__] they do down here
it's for young
people I stay in the hotel room that's
my deal um I did go for a little walk
around town I took a little stroll you
know how it is down here in the South
man you get out there in that weather
you know I'm working here with uh Dean
he's going dude this weather is [__]
perfect and I'm like well [__] enjoy
it dude this is the Calm before the
[__] global warming storm we sitting
in this barbecue joint and the [__]
guys up on the TV doing the weather the
[__] map is all yellow orange and red
it's like it's
November it's [__]
November what what are you going to do
what are you going to do sociopaths run
the world and you have to pick a side
you got to pick which sociopath you're
going with um that's how the game works
cuz they control the game speaking of
sociopaths I finally read up on a little
bit on uh Donald Trump and uh Joe Biden
Jr there Hunter G to give him a strong
name Hunter and uh it's [__]
hilarious they just they're literally
getting busted for [__] that everybody
does kind of like M the University of
Michigan like I don't understand this
whole [__] where it was like
Michigan was stealing signs it's like
everybody stealing signs that's why when
you watch the game they disguise the
sign they put the clipboard up over
there face they I've said this for years
they're holding a sign up there's like a
cupcake on there a picture of a dog and
then like [__] you know Fonzi from
Happy Days why do you think they're
doing that cuz people are trying to
steal
signs and it's a skill if you don't put
the right [__] TV star up there and
they can't figure you know and they
figure out what it is I mean that's on
you I love how they act they were
stealing signs so then they're acting
like they knew exactly what the opponent
was doing every single play every single
game it's so [__] stupid so basically
what happened is Michigan pissed
somebody off the way Donald Trump pissed
somebody off that's basically what it is
it's all [__] good until you piss
somebody off and then they hold you to
the air quote
rules so old Donnie boy the
[__] DA's coming the doj is coming
they're [__] going after this guy cuz
he falsified the value I guess of his
assets to get favorable loans and
insurance and it's not like he was off
by a couple of million they are alleging
at one point he had a golf course with
$27.5 million and he had it on his loans
or whatever applying for a loan as being
worth upwards of 1.5
billion okay you do that according to
them and then you sign the piece of
paper you're guilty of fraud okay I'll
go with that but what about the [__]
Banks what about the insurance companies
aren't they supposed to check that
out you telling me I could go to a bank
and have some [__] hole house and be
like yeah it's worth a trillion dollars
I'd like a [__] half a trillion
dollar loan okay does everything on this
document true yes yes it is okay I've
done my due diligence as a
banker um yeah it's the greedy [__]
bankers and the greedy [__] insurance
companies they basically they knew what
the [__] he was doing like they all do
it and they went along with it cuz they
believed in him that he wasn't going to
default on his [__] loans and that
game is all well and good until somebody
defaults on the loan I don't know if
that's what he did cuz I remember him
when he was running for office he was
like I took advantage of the uh the
bankruptcy laws nobody's ever done it
better in fact I know more about the
bankruptcy laws than anybody all that
[__] and I remember his side they
were so [__] stupid they were
cheering him on it's like guys that's
our money that's our money he defaulted
on the [__] loans do you think the
bank's going to lose money they don't
they take it out of us he was basically
standing there saying I got a bunch of
your money and never paid it back and
you guys paid the tab and people gave
him like a [__] Standing Ovation so
then Hunter little Coke head over there
you know he took the White House a
little literal
there I guess this saying his dad
Dad how much money you want to take from
Syria he was getting bribes oh my God
what a surprise a political official
getting
bribes they're set up to be bribed
they're so [__] grossly underpaid
that's how the corporations ruined this
country they weren't making they they
were basically for the level that they
were at they were getting paid like an
NFL cheerleader to have all of us yell
at them and tell them that they didn't
know what the [__] they were doing they
got sick of getting yelled at so they
took the payoffs from the corporations
Oh Billy making it so simple he read a
couple of Articles so Bill tell us how
the world works I'm going to oh I'm
going to so I guess uh old JoJo there if
he can
remember was taking payoff some other
countries probably to you know give him
Aid or I don't know what the [__] so he
could get a house on Math's Vineyard
although he's white he's probably going
to n
Tucket and then he ran him through
Hunter and he was too coked up to
realize he was getting [__] used and
now he's sitting there holding the bag
now he's the
psy is that what's going on
like I think all of that's the say
Michigan Donald Trump and Hunter Biden
that's all the same [__]
story um well not really Michigan
Michigan I think is
[__] and I don't like Ohio State but
even if Ohio State got busted for like
stealing signs I just don't think
stealing
signs is a uh I just don't
think you know that's that's how you win
a war it's a skill and you got to try to
figure out what they're doing it's it's
it's it's a riddle wrapped up in Enigma
with the [__] Steve Urkel sign right
if you can figure that out maybe you get
an advantage on one or two plays but
that's it that it doesn't like I mean I
guess if you got the advantage on the
very last play and you were [__] you
know up by one or some [__] maybe that
would be it I don't [__] know seems
like a whole bunch of nothing to me but
you know what you know what I'm a simple
man you know what I'm saying I put my
pants on one freckled leg at a time and
I I try not to be involved but he had a
day off in New
York and I'm an old man so I still buy
the paper and it's funny I had to go to
a couple of delies like in New York like
they all sold the paper now the
newspaper's going away you
know that's bad those were like the more
wholesome lies that I grew up with used
to be in the newspaper so I like reading
those lies because I can read them in my
voice you know as opposed to watching
the 24-hour news networks where they
just sensationalize everything and you
know scare the [__] out of you blame the
other side and then offer no Solutions
whatsoever is you know lot more times
they're not I feel like they're getting
paid by the people that they're uh
complaining about maybe to look the
other way I don't know I tie it all
together I tie it together somehow
somehow I'll I'll blame this all on Ohio
State or Alabama some
point some point in this [__] podcast
but uh last
night uh I was in norfol Virginia and I
played this place it is the most
beautiful [__] Arena one of the most
beautiful Arenas in the
country
um you got to be kidding me is that
somebody [__] I'm okay thank
you they just won't leave you alone they
just [__] won't you know what's
overrated a nice hotel and you know what
else is overrated going out to a nice
restaurant cuz the entire time they
won't [__] leave you alone you go to
a nice restaurant every time you start
to have a [__] conversation somebody
comes over with the water and you got to
be like oh no I'm good or oh hey thanks
a
lot is everybody doing good do you want
more
bread is anybody can I get you anything
can I can I can I do something yes you
can [__] off we ordered food bring the
food and then leave and then when the
plates are empty come back and then you
give us a check and we give you a
[__] tip and then we get the [__] out
of here what am I a child you going to
cut up my [__] steak for me [__]
beat
it you know [__] nice hotel right
you don't want to go back you don't want
to go beyond a Marriot marri [__]
leaves you alone you check in it's a
nice [__] place right you go anything
nicer than a Marriot they're coming in
they're bringing like hey can can turn
you want turn down service I I I don't I
don't know what that is you're going to
tuck me in it's [__] 7:00 at night
old Billy big problems here
um sorry um I'm just more frustrated I'm
trying to do a [__] podcast every 5
seconds it's just you know you just hear
like Let Me Wait I I can't get to a wall
here
just you want some more
celery um why would they give you celery
you know why cuz it's cheap and they can
give you a lot of it and they'll make it
seem like they're doing something um
anyway I played the I think it's called
the Scope Arena is that what it's called
yeah the Scope Arena and I was just
blown away by the beauty of this thing s
c o p e look it up you have to go go see
a concert there you got to go see some
hockey or some basketball there it's 50
years old they broke around in 1968 and
when they built they built it their
first tenant I believe was the V uh the
Virginia
Squires an ABA team who the one and only
Dr J played
on um before he went to the New York
Nets before he went to the NBA with the
Philadelphia
76ers and we were there last night and
it was the best sounding Arena I've been
in and just the look of it and
everything it was like it felt old
school and it felt modern it's
absolutely gorgeous and I don't ever
hear of anybody going out of their way
people go out of their way to go to
Madison Square Garden or like uh I don't
know the Forum in LA but there's some
hidden gems I I I would say the most
underrated Arena to go see [__]
anything would be the Scope Arena the
people there was so
nice um I had an amazing show just one
of those shows I went up there I
immediately clicked with the crowd and
they went with everything and
um yeah I texted my agent the next
morning going that that has to be a
regular stop you know provided I can
sell that many tickets when I get old
like [__] really old like Billy Joel
how about Billy Joel still playing the
SOI [__]
Arena that's unbelievable just going out
there just him and a piano like four
other guys selling out the whole [__]
thing and the football
field guy is a beast um anyway tonight I
am in
Atlanta which some of my most favorite
standup comedy weekends gigs venues ever
there was the original
punchline that was one of my favorite
comedy clubs in the country
unfortunately you know they raised the
least I don't know they probably built
some [__] luxury apartments that
nobody can [__] afford which they
were also doing in northfalk Virginia
like I don't know what they're doing or
where all of this money is coming from
I'm just finding everybody is hurting
right now I'm seeing people saying like
a [__] Big Mac at McDonald's is like
15 bucks now and all of this
inflation and rather than trying to do
something to help people out they're
just building more [__] that nobody can
afford and they're knocking down [__]
that people could afford so what the
[__] is going on you know what it is
it's a Ponzi scheme is what it is there
so um every time I go to watch the news
like every time I take a peek at what's
going on in the Gaza Strip it is just so
[__]
heartbreaking seeing all of those
innocent people on both sides because of
the lunatics at the
top just getting killed and made I I
don't know how you sit there and watch
there's like nothing you can do about
it and then it's just [__] horrible
right so I I don't know what do we do we
have to somehow Bond as nons sociopath
regular
people and we just have to start helping
each other out because these [__]
[__] at the
top and and as far as I can tell in
every country they're not doing anything
I mean look at the broads over there in
Iceland I thought they were all skipping
around with goats in that beautiful
world having a great time they were
[__]
pissed they're like we're not making
enough money everybody's over oh Iceland
they stood up to the banks oh they'll go
to the [__] Blue Lagoon and the the
waterers crystal clear and there's
mermaids and [__] blah blah
blah and it's not it's a bunch of angry
broads over there getting [__] over
evidently and what's [__] up is
they're all related so they're they're
literally it's beyond [__] over your
own countrymen you're [__] over your
family I told you that guys that a long
time ago when I went to Iceland I found
out that there's an app over
there that people in Iceland have that
when you meet some chick in a bar or
dude whatever you're [__] into you
have to well I guess a dude wouldn't
matter cuz you're if you're gay you're
not going to breed with them and it's
like Open Season I guess
um but if you're going to have that
heterosexual sex like Jesus approved of
when he got that hooker um there's an
app over there it doesn't say
that you put your names
in I guess when you decide you're going
to go forward and maybe [__] you put
your names in it there's no way they do
this every
time this is like [__] without a
condom in Iceland you don't use the
[__] app it it doesn't check to see
if you're related it's how you're
related cuz it goes back to two [__]
people like some Adam and Eve [__] but
it was a couple of Vikings I don't know
what they were right you know I've only
spent collectively 4 and a half days
there so let me explain this country to
you such an idiot so anyway yeah that's
what you do and then you
decide so I guess what they really do is
not until they get into a relationship
it's probably after they banged it's
like all right let's
see let's
see let's see if uh we can go to holy
matrimony or if we just did something
Unholy
um anyway the [__] am I talking about oh
yeah so the punch line they knocked that
down so now now they have the the second
punch line but the original one is the
one that I
worked um that I have all my memories
and I still like the new one but the old
one you know it's like the old it's like
the stadium you grew up in right I like
the Fleet Center but I'm I'll always be
partial to the Boston Garden and then
after that place I played the
Tabernacle um in Atlanta there's another
place all right all of these [__]
people telling you you got to go to
these places with palm trees and [__]
you don't so many of these cities that
nobody brings up have these amazing
venues that you can go see your favorite
comedian your favorite band whatever the
[__] it is your tractor pull whatever
the [__] you're into the Tabernacle you
wouldn't have a tractor pull there
unless they had golf carts it's not big
enough but um
magical magical [__] place where you
go see a band that plays
live and um at least I would anyway and
everybody has is playing their
instruments and as Prince said In that
clip you know my mic is
on that's my favorite thing my mic is on
I would go check that place
out this is like my own travel show here
there's two [__] places you know we
had some friends come out and they said
the last time I was here one of them
said the last time I came here CU it was
a bit of a drive for him he said he saw
Metallica at the Scope Arena on the end
Justice for All tour a [__] sick as
that and
um I didn't even have to ask the guy I
was like that's automatically that band
that era that Arena had to have been top
five [__] concerts she ever went to
had to
be um so anyway um the Scuttle butt on
the internet all this crap about Bill
bich so they get rid of him I'm sure the
whole league is salvaing hoping our
local news media and uh
armchair
quarterbacks like I I know I know we
okay we have the worst
record in the AFC so what we still have
Bill bich as a coach I think the guy has
earned the right to try to dig out of a
hole what is every draft pick supposed
to work out I mean we had an
unbelievable run I'm still basking in
the glow of going to nine Super Bowls
and winning
six the [__] am I you
know what do I give a I can handle 2 and
seven what's he not going to turn it
around I don't know look I mean I what
about the [__] Buffalo Bills they've
never won anything they were supposed to
be finally figuring [__] out to go beat
the Kansas City Chiefs they're what are
they they only got like three more wins
than we do so what what's the big
[__]
deal
um I always feel like those sports rers
that's that's just what they they just
end up doing that you know because they
don't know what else to write about so
they get lazy and they just try to stir
people up and I guess they know that if
they say something sacreligious like is
it time to give Bill bich his Walking
Papers everyone's going to get all up in
a [__]
frenzy
um I don't know that would
be if they fired him after everything
that he's done I like I said last week
that would be right up there with
Charles Oakley getting thrown out of
Madison Square Garden which in recent
times you know a lot of franchises have
done stupid
[__] with former players that did
amazing things but to literally throw
the guy out like he was some
drunk
um I don't know that's that's one I felt
bad for for all Nick fans when that
happened because I know they were all
going every Nick fan I knew was just
like dude what the [__] like what why
the hell you
know haven't we been through enough you
got to add that to the
[__] Championship drought here over
here speaking of that um with the sports
I've been out on the road so I haven't
had time to watch these Bruins games but
I guess we won again we finally had our
first loss I want to say it was against
the Red Wings but we're something like
91 and one or 101 and one which is
incredible because we lost Patrice
berson and David craie and this was you
know he signed van rdik and stuff like
that and I had a lot of buddies of mine
going like H I think they you know they
only signed van dreams dike for one year
and this is just so we can be
competitive and they can still sell
tickets and here they are with like the
best record in hockey as far as I know
so um so far so good so far so good no
Billy
freckles still hitting the treadmill I
kind of
[__] like I don't know leveled out
here I I got to do more more of a push I
got to eat better man I got to lay off
the I've like laid off [__]
everything and it's still [__] hard
as hell you know 55 Jesus Christ it's a
race between what's slower at this point
my brain and my [__]
metabolism but
um I got this playlist any ACDC fans out
there huh I got a Brian Johnson playlist
for you it's all deep cut [__] you know
because they always play the same
[__] five Brian Johnson songs I feel
so this is my playlist 31 minutes eight
songs all right first one let me put my
love into you babe ACDC Back and black
you know start slow just like me on the
elliptical I did my little soccer mom
stretches you know what I
mean I got my little
drink I got on my [__] pink leg
warmers you know I'm easing in
then you go to one of the great [__]
Gold Digger songs
ever uh what do you do for money honey
also off the Back in Black Album and
then the Bon Scott tribute song Have a
Drink on
Me Off the back and Black Album that's
that's the first three so see we're
we're ramping it
up all right I start with ease it in
easing in with let me put my love on a
you babe then uh they scream at the
broads and now we're at the bar having a
drink so what can come
next huh it's ACDC you know the devil's
coming right
Cod second track second side back in the
day when you had the vinyl or the
cassette tape car of the
devil then we keep going with the devil
I got evil walks which is the first
track second side ACDC For Those About
to Rock and then I round out that album
with Spellbound
which is a very uh a very atypical
subject matter for ACDC it's actually
about a guy down in the dumps and he's
depressed it's a killer song but I feel
like collectively as a group they're
like that's not what we do we don't talk
about being down you know I don't think
there'll ever be rock and roll music
that's just supposed to bring it down do
you guys think so 8 years later grunge
you know I wish I was like
you easily
amused okay so wait let me get this
straight Kurt I'm supposed to feel bad
for you as you're [__] on
me I love K Cain I love Nana but I can
never quite give it up to the grunge
bands because they knocked all my bands
off the [__] chart I'm still being a
baby still being a baby all these years
later all right then we wrap it up with
the last
two off the flick of the switch album
this house is on fire and then the title
track flick of the
switch
um which used to always [__] me up when
I would try to play drums along to that
it was
like
slam one two three 4 One Two Three 4
boom and I always would want to hit on
the four but he [__] hits on the one
does a flam on the one and then on the
four and then [__] in the amount of
times I [__] that up and I would slam
on the floor and then they'd hit on the
one and i' go [__] four bam and then I
would go into the song um someone
actually took some video of me playing
drums the other day and uh for the first
time I only look like half a jerk
off I still hit like a [__] [__] man
I always think I'm up there [__]
wailing that I'm not I'm just up there
like I hope I'm do it right like I'm in
my head I'm like Jesus Christ these
people I'm jamming with they're thinking
like why did this guy pick comedy how
come he didn't pick music as a
profession and then I always start to
watch myself I'm like uh I've just never
had the courage to film myself on a
consistent basis and that's kind of like
what you have to do to stop looking like
a douche I think or maybe you know I
could just own up to the fact that I
wasn't born with that Talent you know
and I'll just be forever that guy going
into a music store going I want to buy
the snare drum that that guy plays on
that album cuz I feel like if I play the
same stuff he plays that means I'll be
as good as he
is which is hilarious cuz we all wear
Jordan Ones you know what is the
percentage of people that wear Jordan
Ones but can't
[Music]
dunk that is it has to be in the high 9s
it just has to
be um unless you count like a Nerf hoop
or that backyard one that you lowered to
like eight you know 8 and 1/2 ft 9 ft
was
actually was actually for you know for a
[__] pasty white guy if you could
[__] throw it down in a 9 foot Rim
that wasn't bad
um yeah I grew up in white town so I was
like dude he can he can dunk a tennis
ball that's about as far as it went I
think one kid dunked a volleyball um was
more of a football hockey town but uh
those are also two great Sports wouldn't
you say hey you know what I don't have
any advertising this week so I just got
to go straight through here no ad
reads you know it's a tough time coming
up to the holidays I started shopping
you know for the
kids I wanted to get my kid
um my son I wanted to get him that
100-year uh Bruins away jersey the white
one cuz it looks like the home Jersey
that the that the Bruins wore in the80s
that the one that I that's my favorite
one is the the the all white one that
had it was white on the shoulders it
didn't have that yellow up there the one
that Pete Peters wore Rick Middleton and
all of those guys charie
simmer Barry
Peterson
unreal I can't remember the name of the
venue I was in last night but I can name
like the [__] first line of the
Bruins in like 198 well no maybe I can't
well Barry Peterson was there
it was Barry Peterson Peter
McNab Peter McNab the last guy to wear
number eight before Cam Neely came in
and that was when Ray Bourke was still
wearing number seven because we had a
big beef with Phil F bazito and then
they finally put that to bed which by
the way is there anything better than
listening to Phil Esposito on the radio
calling a Tampa Bay Lightning game it's
like it's not even like he's in a booth
it's like you're at the game with him
and he's sitting in the stands e [__]
peanuts and having a couple of beers
it's [__]
incredible very very underrated
um announcer man I uh I just you know I
have the the ceriz package but it's not
the radio but he used to be on TV too
and that was my favorite but I think he
just does the radio now maybe does like
select games I don't know he's got to be
he's got to be close to 80 um but I
would love to uh if you guys know how to
get that feed
you know that's one of thing you get to
enjoy hockey and you're laughing your
ass off at the same time that's like the
greatest thing ever and uh I miss those
guys I miss those [__]
homers you know Johnny Mo for the
Celtics Fred cusk for the Bruins I mean
we could do literally do no wrong was
hilarious what sucks now is everybody
can hear him so then they just sit there
this guy's such a [__] Homer it's
like he's supposed to be he's not
announcing the game for you go listen to
the [__]
your teams
feed you telling me they're not biased
you want them to be
biased especially when you're losing
they start ah this is [__] [__]
they don't say that but you
know you know it's nice to hear that
they give a [__] before they just all
they all to do like the the I don't know
what the Straight Ahead color
commentating by the way uh shout out to
Joe Buck that guy's having like some of
the best games he's called
called um since I've been watching him
and Troy aan man I am and I am a
broadcaster
snob you know cuz I grew up with so many
great ones so um and what always happens
is they become you know there's like a
transition like uh so many of the guys
that I grew up with you know retired
times
two you know and every once in a while
I'll like watch an old football clip and
I'll hear John and Pat
sumerall and I just think like I can't
believe like I just I never took it for
granted but like that I got to listen to
those
guys I think John Madden came on with
Pat sumerall somewhere around like
1980 and I get to listen to them for
almost like you know 20 years 15 20
years together all those Al Michaels
ones um I caught the end of Kurt
gouty um you know who else I liked who I
really liked when I was growing up he
always seemed to get the Browns game
remember Don cricky was another guy that
was
amazing um anyway uh that's the podcast
here I got to go do a show um I want to
thank everybody that came out in
northfalk Virginia you guys were one of
the best crowds that I C that I've ever
had it was just an incredible
show
um incredible crowd sitting here talking
about myself incredible crowd you guys
were an incredible group of people to
perform to it was fantastic so
I'll write some more [__] and I'll come
back and
um I I would go out of my way to go see
a show there I'm going to I'm going to
get on their mailing list the Scope
Arena all right that's it uh have a
great weekend you cun enjoy the bonus
episode of a Thursday uh the Thursday
afternoon just before Friday Monday
Morning podcast I'm [__] getting
geared up here from Madison Square
Garden Beyond psyched that I'm getting
to play this place again I always think
anytime I play it this could be the last
time and uh I am going to [__] go off
so um I hope you're going to be there if
not no worries because eventually I'll
be in your town all right I'll see
[Music]
you hey what's going on it's Bill bur
and it's time for the Monday Morning
podcast for Monday November 9th 2015
what's going on how are you how's it
going easing into
Thanksgiving I apologize for the podcast
being so late and the pe's popping on
the microphone turn that down there
um I just been traveling like a maniac
man I've Been Everywhere man I did
Philly and then I did Bethlehem
Pennsylvania and then I went to Daytona
Florida and oh what a time I had what a
[__] time for old freckles it's good
to be freckles these days his [__]
year is winding down I always wonder
what my neighbors think when I [__]
come back to New York like what what
where is that loud [__] been in a
[__] coma haven't heard his stupid
podcast forever my [__] roach
infested goddamn apartment back here
came walking in like this just
[__] you know I have the guy come in
and spray it but I don't know they still
get in here you know they just [__]
dead
everywhere but they're so [__] old
from being dead right I pick them up and
like the antenna stays on the
floor it's [__]
gross so
anyways um what was they talking about I
don't even
remember whatever yeah I just been I've
been all over the place so um I want to
thank everybody that came out to my
shows this weekend in uh Philadelphia in
Bethlehem and in Daytona I had a [__]
awesome time and each show was special
in its own own little way um the first
[__] night was the uh was the philly
show right so I go to Philly and
contrary to one [__] YouTube video
everybody thinks I hate Philly I don't I
was actually this is some [__] I've
never really even told you guys I was
actually a Flyers fan growing up because
when I first started watching hockey I
loved the fact that you could fight and
that's what the Flyers did so I loved
them
you know I was too too young to remember
them beating us in the Stanley Cup Final
in the 70s so I didn't have any bad will
against the guys I just knew that they
beat the [__] out of people and who
doesn't want to watch that you know I
ease my way into violence you know
started off by getting my ass kicked by
my older brother then I started watching
wrestling and then I moved on to hockey
right years later I'm watching the UFC
it just keeps progressively getting more
fun I watch those knockout videos I
watch people getting
slapped you
know um there has to be a [__] word
for the level of excited the person
holding the cell phone uh camera has
when they start screaming world star it
literally sounds like they're on fire
they're so [__] excited that they
filmed a knockout and that they're going
to get it on the [__] website like
they're almost like peeing themselves I
do an impression of it but I have a show
I have to do in about 8 days and it
would shred my [__] voice I'll try to
I was going to lie to you and say I was
going to try and find the clip I have no
idea where the clip where the clip is
but um so anyway so uh I went got into
Philly on Thursday night had the big
shoe really big shoe there on Friday so
I was like all right let me go out and
get a cheese steak and it was really
late and I I didn't have a car and I
just said [__] it I said to the guys
downstairs they go all right where uh
where's the closest place to get a good
one and they kind of made a face you
know all right go down the corner so I
went to this place cavanos it's a sports
bar one of the coolest thing I saw they
had the N the the [__] Phillies
1980 um World Series Banner in there
which was cool and I went in I got it
with the tater tots and I got to tell
you it was pretty [__] tasty pretty
goddamn tasty straight across the board
I give the [__] Cheese Steak at at uh
at Kavanagh the [__] thumbs up right
so then the next day right we got the
show so I'm walking around I'm doing
what I always do with when I go to
Philly right [__] checking out the
downtown area and I always end up over
at Mitchell and Nest just to see what
the [__] they have and uh I bought my
godson
something and uh what else did I do I
just walked around I [__] you know I
enjoy the goddamn City I don't do the
touristy [__] you know I meant to check
out the Joe Fraser [__] um
statue but I didn't have time um so
anyways so we got to go do the [__]
show right it's at the Wells fago Arena
speaking of the Flyers and the [__]
76ers and all that [__] so me verie and
Joe mates are on the show Mates is from
Philly so we're driving over there I'm
using the [__] you
know I finally changed in the phone I
changed it to a guy's voice so at least
it's a guy telling me what to do suppos
that [__] broad nagging me the whole
way right causing my balls to pull up
into me right so I [__] um we're
driving over there and of course we
somehow we get lost trying to find a
[__] Arena and I literally see it
says parking for event but the [__]
computer [__] didn't tell me to turn or
my thumb grazed against something and
just shut the [__] thing off so I
went right by it and when you missed the
Wells Fargo Center headed south you end
up in the [__] swamp so it ended up
being like a half hour mistake cuz it
was like 15 minutes to get all the way
over the [__] thing and then we
didn't know how to get in there we went
into the wrong [__] gate so we pull
in they're charging us for parking and
I'm going no we're the guys doing the
show I'm Bill Burr that's Joe mice
that's Paul ver so the lady's like hang
on a second she's like yeah he said he's
Paul
Burr so we're laughing our asses off
going I swear to God we're them and they
go well tell us a joke
and I was like I don't have any [__]
jokes the well the three comedians we
can't find a [__] arena is that funny
enough and they go all right go down
there to gate e and we just keep running
into security guards and we just keep
going yeah we're the guys from the show
and they would just go oh all right go
down that way so then we just started
laughing going dude I'm going to pull up
to Arena and be like yeah I'm Willie
Nelson yeah man I uh I'm a little late
where do I go I obviously I couldn't get
away with Willie Nelson he's too famous
but I'm telling you this is how it
works okay you need somebody black and
somebody white in your car and I
guarantee you you could sneak into any
[__] Arena when there's a concert all
right this is all you got to do all
right have a black and a white person in
there just in case you get into the
wrong line then what you do is you try
to peek ahead to see what color the
person is in the parking Booth if
they're white you have the black guy
talk right the black guy says I'm
[__] uh
wait you what you got to start with the
artist first all right so say what what
are the kids listening to these days huh
ASAP Rocky right say he's got a [__]
show what you got to do is you got to
have your black friend or you got to get
a black friend or just hire a black guy
you have him say you pull up to the
wrong [__] gate the regular person
gate you make sure you get in line with
the [__] white person right in the
booth and you all you black gu got to
say is yeah him and I'm late man where
do I go where do I go and I'm telling
you that guy will [__] wave you in
least you won't have to pay for parket I
don't know if it [__] works and then
if it's a [__] country show your
black friend's not going so who gives a
[__] you only need white people anyways
whatever I'm convinced oh [__] me hang
on a second hang on hang
on all right I'm back yeah see black
friend's not going to want to go to the
country showing all I'm saying is if you
just if you [__] pull
up
no wait a minute they probably know it
all they this is me being an ego Maniac
this is what this is they didn't know
who I am so then they're not going to
who know who [__] Travis trit is what
an arrogant freckled [__] I apologize I
apologize not only for this thing being
late but having my ego go off the
[__] rails that soon in this podcast
right it's [__] unbelievable it
usually takes me at least 15 minutes in
before the ego starts coming out oh it
reared its [__] red head early didn't
it um so anyways we were [__] driving
around that parking lot for like 20
minutes and I'm talking to the guy in
the [__] Arena and he's going you
know where are you I'm like well I'm in
the [__] parking lot it's it's we're
in E and he goes all right did you go
into the tunnel and I'm like no I went
over a bridge we bringing around a
[__] thing it took us like for
[__] ever and then we got in
there and um we got to go into the
obviously go into the venue before the
crowd got in there got to see the you
know they got the boards you know where
the
[__] you know for the Flyers play and
all that [__] I saw the 76ers 83
Championship Banner the team that I
would put up against the 96 bulls and I
say it goes seven games you
know um oh me and ver got into it that
night holy [__] arguing Sports good Lord
he was like dude they're [__] 72 and
10 you know he's one of those 1990s
babies like nothing happened in sports
prior to
1990 nobody dude they had Pippen they
had Jordan like that [__] [__] it's
like all right well they had Dr J in
Moses
Malone you know and Mo Cheeks [__]
Andrew Tony and ivarone
right that [__] skinny white dude
coming off the goddamn bench who was
like the defensive player of the year
dude Moses Malone underneath against
Luke Longley Luke Longley is going to
[__] foul out he's going in foul
trouble every [__] game all right I'm
not saying that the Sixers definitely
would have [__] won but you just say
that it's a foregone conclusion that the
[__] 96 Bulls are the greatest
[__] team ever they had there was no
Celtics Lakers thing going on with the
[__] it was a very uneven time you
know and people oh it's because Jordan
was so good I'll give you a little bit
of that all right but dude when the
[__] Celtics Lakers and Sixers were
all good in the [__] 80s and then the
Pistons came along I mean dude you had
to [__] commit mass murder just to
get to the
finals people throwing clothesline Kurt
ramus's glasses flying across the
[__] Court it was a man's [__]
game I'm being that old guy no I know it
was in the '90s to but I'm just
saying there wasn't any Kareem there
wasn't there wasn't like you know the
Celtics and Lakers were [__] littered
with Hall of Famers on both sides you
know I don't know what am I [__] Bill
Simmons I don't know [__] about [__]
hoop I'm just saying I just hate out
everybody oh yeah he do this and he do
that and and Moses and Dr J would just
stand around watching him going gee holy
holy mackerel golly Gia these guys good
um we get into that AR argument all the
time and he also gets the argument that
Mayweather is the greatest [__]
middleweight of all time I'm like
Paul Marvin Hagler the problem is Marvin
Haggler Sugar Ray Leonard Tommy Hitman
Hearns and Roberto Duran all fought at
the same [__] time so they took
losses you know what I mean I'm not
saying that he would lose to all of
those guys but he'd lose to at least one
of them wouldn't he oh I sound like an
old man in a barber shop um I'll try
back in
1972 [__] voice is junk dude it's
junk doing all these [__] shows and
uh I got to be honest with you man I am
I'm [__] I'm done with cigars man I
smoked my last one in Philly and I
didn't even want to smoke it I just did
it cuz uh we with a bunch of people and
they you know they wanted to head over
there but I didn't even tell you about
the show so verie goes up to open
it [__]
crushes and uh which made me feel really
good you know obviously cuz the last
time I did a really big show out there
um you know things were a little more
aggressive so to speak and I had a lot
of people interviewers asking me about
it cuz I wasn't even thinking about it
because I've been back to Philly like
six [__] times and I never had a
problem but they just kept well this is
a big show so do you think this
one huh do you think they're going to
treat you like an
[__] as they say in Philly [__] um
and then Joe matares went up by the way
who I hadn't seen you know he's a guy I
started out with uh when I first came to
New York he moved to New York right
around the time that I did came up from
Philly and I came down from Boston and
uh you know he's even funny that I
remembered he absolutely [__]
destroyed did a dead
on uh was it Harry Callas I saying his
name right um sounded exactly like him
now Philly people know him as the voice
of the Phillies I knew him from NFL
films taken over for the voice of God
and um he absolutely murdered and uh I
highly recommend you check that guy out
uh um if you get a chance and you can
follow him on Twitter at the Joe mates m
a t a r s e the Joe mates uh I believe
he's got a special or something like
that coming out um he was [__]
hilarious and then when we were driving
away he was doing a dead on Tony Soprano
[__] dead
on it it was Unreal so um we had a great
time and then we ended up going out and
uh we smoked some cigars
I was a good boy I had one glass of
bourbon that was it I smoked a cigar and
me and verie were at each other's
throats [__] arguing Sports and um
and then when we left we got cheese
steak number two number two
two um and where did we go we went to
something like Mike's prin of staks or
something like that I can't even
remember I don't remember the name of it
but um that one I thought the bread was
good
I thought everything was good but the
steak I thought the steak wasn't as high
of
quality um as what I had at kavanau and
I'm not even talking about was it Pats
and Goos I I've been to those [__]
things I'm trying to go to the satellite
ones um I didn't even get to the ones
that roast beef one was closed by seven
so I never made it to that one but um I
still had a good time but Jesus Christ
what a [__] [__] show if you want to
see a [__] show get a [__] Cheese
Steak at 2:00 in the morning in
Philadelphia on a Friday night good Lord
people just swaying in the [__]
Breeze right and then the people I
walked in with they were [__]
hammered too I wasn't I'm [__] sober
right go walking in mat goes like like
way too loud like drug voice he goes he
goes yep every [__] loser in Philly
out here to get a cheese steak and I was
like Joe Joe shut the [__] up shut the
[__] up you
know
then F he
goes he goes Jesus Christ he goes look
at the haircut on that [__] animal
over there way too loud way too [__]
loud I'm going Paul Paul shut the [__]
up shut the [__] so I was that guy I was
basically the not even designated driver
like a designated Walker and everybody
in there I swear to God was swaying they
were so drunk like 90% of the people in
there were swaying I felt like I was on
a [__] ship and was some salty dog
who had his sea legs and everybody else
was just sort of [__] floating around
so anyways we get the cheesecakes I [__]
up the order the guy's all impatient
with me and I was going to be oh you're
doing that Philly thing well you get all
[__] impatient cuz I don't know how
to go give me two wi give me a whis wit
no whiz notot you know so um so I got
that little experience and then uh as we
were eating we we were finishing up
right at the the exact right time like
the uh the white white
dude with uh all black friends came
walking in and he was trying to you know
I don't know what he was trying to do he
was unbelievably loud he was being
[__] rude and he was going to get all
of his friends into a
fight when we [__] left I was like
let's get the [__] out of here and
um I don't know I had a great time I
actually also ate a really good
breakfast place little pets I think it
was called greasy spoon I [__] loved
it and the lady behind the counter was a
who works the day shift is a [__]
riot I was sitting there she got me my
drink order and she goes you ready and I
was like yeah she goes what do you got
and I just laughed I go let me get two
eggs uh [__] what do you got what do
you got I don't know hunger
pains um so anyway so we had a great
time there and
uh as I said I can't recommend uh going
out to see Joe mice enough man like he
[__] blew me away ver of course was
great as always but uh I always like
throwing out new names on the podcast
people you could check out the Joe mates
on
Twitter um hang on I'm punching
this never can talk and do my password
at the same [__] time if I went into
my settings and figured out how to make
the screen saver not come up every two
[__]
seconds um all right let's do a couple
of reads
here you know what that just reminded me
of I don't know why everybody freaking
out about that [__] missile that the
Navy shot
off you know this is the beginning of
World War II well
great great and then you know what we're
all going to be dead so what are you
[__] worried about you know what I
mean I would be much more worried if
somebody released one Cobra into the
[__] Los Angeles area and I knew that
it was somewhere in the Hills where I
hiked if there was one Cobra there I
would be way more [__] [__]
nervous like if they said right now we
have a special news flash China has just
shot a bunch of nuclear weapons they
will be here in 6 minutes so get your
Affairs in order I would go over to the
fridge and I'd get out of pine of ice
cream and I'd sit there you know you
know like a little kid sits in a big
chair and he kicks his legs up and down
like and a scissor that's what I would
do oh boy oh boy I'm going to get
vaporized I'm getting what everybody
wants a painless death that's what
you're looking at when you see the
nuclear weapons what you're looking at
is a painless death I'm all about them I
love the WarHeads I'm a big Warhead fan
you know I like that we're puffing each
other's chest up you know what I mean
China's you know we're like why
I you know and China's like why we
order and then Korea's like hey what
about us we still count right I don't
give a [__]
I really
don't
um you know I'm a grizzled vet of this
[__] I grew up in the tail end of the
Cold War I remember that [__]
right everybody says they're going to do
it and then they never
do okay until they do and when they do
you're not going to know it cuz it's
going to be over at least I won't know
it that's one of the great things about
being in a targeted City you're going to
have no idea that World War I even
happened you're just going to wake up
you know
wherever the [__] you go or maybe you
just become part of the
radiation you know that the next people
are going to climb out
of I told you guys that my that's my
theory right that water is the nuclear
waste from the last people that [__]
up this planet you know and we're
actually these [__] mutants we're
actually ugly as [__] we just don't know
any better cuz we're attracted to what
we see cuz we're all [__] arrogant
right we got the ego look at me my ego
came out in [__] first six minutes
you don't know who I am well then I
could say I'm Elvis and everyone would
believe it no bill they wouldn't you
[__] dope
um yeah so I don't I don't know what the
big deal is and it was also funny to
watch to read
that and uh listen to say that they was
saying everybody in California was
freaking out and then I call my wife and
she doesn't even bring it
up probably didn't even know what
happened cuz at this point nobody really
watches the news anymore remember the
news used to come
on the [__] everybody watched the
[__] news you had your guy who do you
like and it was all men right cuz men
tell you what's going on in the world
despite what these ladies think you know
what I mean that's why I stopped
watching the news second I saw a woman
news anchor I was like this Brad doesn't
know what she's talking about she does
she only got half the information cuz
whoever was telling it to her was
probably thinking about [__] her and
he left out half the
information okay that's the problem with
female news anchors and I've been saying
it for years and you can hide behind
your
sexist he's a sexist comment all
right there's not an ounce of comedy in
this right now I'm just trying to give
bloggers an easy
week uh I am dead serious you know I
don't even know does Connie Chun still
do it you know what's funny was Connie
Chun did the real news and then her
husband was doing that what was that
[__] show was it hard copy and they
had that sound of sound like a [__]
mat what's that thing behind the door
the door stopper remember that thing you
played with before there was the
internet you just sit there for hours
[Music]
going that's a hard noise to imitate you
just sit there [__] with that right
he was on a show that that was the sound
effect as they went into every story and
Connie right was actually talking about
real [__] that was well at least you
know the edited real [__] our version of
the real [__] that was going on you know
I would Lov them been sitting there as
they both talked
about you know the news stories that
they were excited about you know she was
reporting about the Berlin Wall coming
down and he was talking about to some
paper
boy who [__] the postman's wife you
know what I
mean I don't know I just I guess I just
find relationships
interesting all right Legal Zoom
everybody yeah we're still doing
advertising by the way Legal Zoom
everyone all right so the next night I
went up and I did
uh I did this the Sans casino is proud
to present a wonderful new show a man
and his music and the man is Frank
Sinatra how all you people get in my
room come fly with me you big fat
[__]
[__] um you guys ever hear that album
oh what an album that is it's with the
count basy
Orchestra um there's a
casino there's a town I know where the
hipsters go called bedrock twist twist
there's a Bethlehem Pennsylvania there
was a casino in there that pulls in like
a million dollars a day they make a they
make bank I walked in there I got there
early I talked to this [__]
zombie and she must have hated her job I
don't know what it was but the way she
was talking it was like that just that
sing songy everywhere I'd be like yeah
where's the gym she'd be like okay the
gym is right down the end of the hall
and
you one time
checkout just going like up and like
like she was a robot and someone just
randomly like programmed the same
inflection Arc she started down low and
then she went up high and then she ended
up here and then she came back
down
um and I went in there right I got a
budweis
I sat down and this place was [__]
mobbed mobbed I've never seen so many
dirty jackets in my
life mobbed with white people Asians
black people any kind of people you
could think of was in there place was
[__]
mobbed and I'm sitting it was Saturday
afternoon and I was sitting there going
is there like a [__] championship F
just let out this is [__]
unbelievable and I talked to one of the
owners and he said no dude this [__]
place does a business like it's one of
the top casinos in the country and uh
I'll tell you what else it is it's one
of the top venues I ever performed at I
had the best [__] time I don't know
what it is just certain rooms you walk
into they just they got that magic right
you just you stand to the side of the
stage and just feel it like this is
going to be [__] great and
um I think I did like an I might have
done an hour and a half on that
one oh such a great [__] time such a
great time
um oh you know it's so funny I talked
about trying to get into the Wells Fargo
Center I didn't even talk about the show
so I actually got to do a show um at
that Arena and um Paul and Joe did great
and I walked out and uh crowd was nice
it was so funny man Philly's like we I
was joking with ver like Phil's like the
only city that you go to where you have
you need a game plan like okay if this
happens I'm going to do this or be ready
to do this blah blah blah blah blah
whatever but the the crowd couldn't have
been uh any better and everybody who
worked there was [__] cool as [__]
and uh I was actually bonding with the
one of the flyer fan um security guys
because their team's not doing that well
either [__] Bruins dropped like three
out of four but we won the last one
that's all right
and uh we [__] up and we blew the
Canadians game crai uncharacteristically
taking a dumb penalty but um but I just
you know I had no idea what to expect
this year so I thought we were just
going to get [__] smoked cuz we had
all these new guys and uh they're
playing good you know I don't mind if we
lose a game cuz we [__] up cuz that
can be fixed it's just when you're just
losing because you just simply can't
even compete and I have not seen that
this year so I'm still uh very
optimistic that we're going to make the
playoffs and uh we're going to have a
good showing I think it's going to even
be better next year so anyway so I fly
down to Daytona
right and um oh Giannis papus opened for
me on that last one you know he went out
[__] crushed
it um actually he really [__] crushed
it and went over a little bit so and he
felt it was all apologetic so I [__]
uh I broke his balls for like a good 10
minutes saying I was never going to use
him he went over by like [__] 3
minutes I was like no no no you did
great uh but you're one and done it's
over you're dead to
me so anyways I went down to Dayton I
never been to Dayton I didn't even
realize that and uh I've always wanted
to go to the Daytona 500 why wouldn't
you why wouldn't you want to see people
as [__] brilliant as they are in Pit
Row and then stand in this being in the
stands of some of the dumbest people in
the nation just that whole mcdlt that
juer position huh
be [__]
phenomenal the [__] people trying to
shave off a you know
millisecond thousandth of a second
whatever they're trying to do by
adjusting some God knows what meanwhile
me and a bunch of other morons are just
standing up there hoping somebody
crashes
um so anyways uh so I was like man I
hope I have time to [__] check out
the speedway I don't have a I don't have
a car so I'm walking off the plane and
and you know in the in the the airports
they have those floor to ceiling Windows
as I walk off the jetway and come into
the the little place where you [__]
wait I looked across the uh the to the
other gate that was directly across and
out the window and there was the [__]
Speedway the speedway is right next to
the airport was [__] cool as [__] and
when I was over at my hotel I heard
um I Heard uh this car [__] driving
around the track you know testing God
knows what out really [__] cool so
hopefully I'll get back there and I
performed at an aeronautical school so
everybody in the crowd was either a
pilot was in maintenance Homeland
Security or uh they were actually
learning how to design airplane parts or
aircraft Parts whatever the [__] you
want to call it
um and I had a great time talking to
them especially afterwards and the dean
of students was actually a veteran I
forget what he said he flew
see something or the gunship and I asked
him if he if when he flies now is it a
lot more enjoyable because nobody
shooting at him he goes I don't do it
anymore and I go oh why not why not you
just sick of it he goes no man he goes I
got sh you know he goes when you get
shot down he goes I got a metal in my
knee and in my shoulder he goes goes
yeah he goes you go down once in one of
those you don't want to do it
again so I just sat there with my jaw on
the around listening to his stories but
I could not have had a better
time
um I could not have had a better time at
that uh at that school and uh Vanessa
Fraction opened up she [__]
destroyed um it's just a great time was
just a great [__] run I just did not
get any goddamn sleep so um let me read
the questions here and let me get on
with my [__] life here
um all
right other language
um see hey Bill I'm 23 and my wife will
never
be complete he wrote complete complete
without advice from
what hey Bill I'm 23 and my okay other
language I'm from Czechoslovakia all
right I'm going to do my best to read
this um or maybe I guess I'm just going
to read it how he wrote it hey I'm 23
and my life will never be complete
without advice from 50 yo out of shape
bald head I moved to England just
because of standup sorry for writing
like a total dick but this is my second
language I used to be good comedian back
home Czech Republic but I wanted more
ever since I moved to England I realized
I'm not so funny in English I want to
give it three more years at least
four when I'm able to to do open mics do
you think that non-native speaker can
break in hard work
inbound um yeah Yakov
sharov made an absolute
Fortune um I think I think you
definitely can it's not going to hurt
you look dude if you can figure out
being from the Czech Republic if you can
figure out how to be funny in English
and make those [__] in England laugh
you know if you can make those [__]
people laugh when you go back to your
part of Europe you're going to be the
king and I'll tell you something right
now dude there's nothing wrong with
being the king of the Czech Republic is
it all those [__] smoking hot chicks
over there you'll [__]
destroy dude if everybody in your
country loves you you you'll be a
[__]
zillionaire it's over and who you
competing against who's the Czech
Republic Richard prior or George Carlin
what's the competition dude you're
getting in at the ground floor you could
be the Lenny Bruce over there right I
think it's a great [__] move and I
think you're going to do well just hang
in there cuz no matter where you're at
you're going to be struggling right and
while you're at it you're in England you
got this cool [__] accent
right maybe you can take out your old
[__] Checker there and stick it
between some chicks beef curtains or
whatever the [__] they say over there
all right Eastern
Europe hello small tits Billy boy you
were teasing with coming to Eastern
Europe some time ago would you consider
coming to Poland absolutely I would I
was told the south southern part of
Poland's great and up north along the
water I would be thrilled to see you
live in my country I'm a huge fan as is
everyone who listens to you obviously um
well that's what my ego says sincerely
go [__] yourselves also I remember
watching you and breaking bed and I
wasn't aware of you being such an
awesome person and thinking
every and every time he popped on the
screen I was like who is that van go
looking dude now [__] you um anyway I
you know I can't even is that a
compliment or I don't even know I I
would definitely come to Poland um and I
definitely want to do Eastern Europe and
I was talking to uh my agent the other
day about how we got to do Europe I do
it every other year so I didn't do it
this year I'm going to do it next year
um I do it every other year when I get
my act together you know what I mean
people going over there in the second
[__] language you know in some of
those places people listening to me
speaking English Eng and they don't
speak English as a as a first language I
got to make sure that like you know I
can't be just riffing and [__] around
I can do that in this country I can put
together an act but I'm not flying all
the way over there to do that so I got
to make sure that during my off year
between specials this is the this is how
it works I put the [__]
together I'll take you through the whole
thing I do my special and then
immediately I start doing comedy clubs
any place I can get up at and I get an
hour worth of [__] that I can say by the
time my special comes out and then I
hone that thing to the point where it's
an acceptable level and then I I start
toring with it on the road and then I
just start dropping jokes as better
jokes come in and then when I get it
really ready to go then I do the
European [__] and then I come back and I
tape the special and then that's it then
I start it all over again and it never
ends all
right here's something about Cleo all
right dear Billy bruford I have a theory
on Cleo's behavior and an explan
explanation for her peeing in the house
all right for the those of you who
didn't listen last time or for those of
you in the future who just grabbed this
one out of a whole slew of them how are
you was there a nuclear Holocaust well
great you survived it are you in your
bunker how many more cans of beans can
you eat you [__] what's it like living
in a world without
ESPN oh you know what if you're actually
in a bunker right now in the future and
you're listening to me I should probably
be a little more positive right I should
okay Jess what may makes that little old
ant think he can survive a meltdown from
a nuclear plant everyone knows he's got
sores all over his [__] face cuz he
went out so like he didn't stay
underground that's why you'll be in that
what do they usually bury it's those
those things what they stick all the
drugs in that sit on the wars they stick
them on the back of trucks Freight
Freight [__] things I don't know
whatever they they dealt with during the
second season of The Wire anyway so
um the [__] was I talk oh the [__]
dog so my dog um has been having bladder
issues every once in a while she just
like pees for no [__] reason and um
our doctor was saying that's because you
know she was spayed and that's one of
the things that happens sometimes once
they get older so this guy has a theory
as to why she's been peeing a little bit
in the house she says I he says I'm or
he or she what do we got here I don't
know all right I'm a lifelong dog
lover um I [__] my first dog when I
was four sorry it was an easy joke I'm a
lifelong dog lover and and own two of my
own remember last week you commented on
how when you got back from Taurus she
slept all night and then was sleeping in
your office while you did the podcast
like she was on morphine totally knocked
out it's because she loves you you are
the one person who takes her on hikes
and gives her baths Etc she's probably
anxious when you're away and when you
come home she's so relieved and relaxed
that she just passes out now that I knew
I'm asking about the peeing here sir all
right don't be answering apples with
oranges now you're about to leave for
tour and she's peeing in the house dogs
are very intuitive and get picked up on
the littlest thing she's picked up on
signs that she'll be leaving again and
as a result is feeling anxious which is
causing her to pee inside
pee inside the house you mean she's peed
inside like what inside of her just a
thought but it could be what's going on
I think that's a great [__] Theory
good luck and see see you next weekend
in New York all right you know what
thank you it's [__] phenomenal advice
way better than anything I've ever said
on this podcast oh come on Bill don't
don't beat up on yourself well I know
all right 8 89-year-old T stand up for
the very first time
um hey Bill did you see the article in
the video of the old guy trying stand up
for the first time at the first at first
the video came out and he was praised
then it came out that he lifted the
jokes and some people turned on him
saying it wasn't that big of a deal if
he memorized him I feel both ways seems
like he could have put together a couple
of on liners with all the old people
downtime he has other part of me says he
just wanted to stand in those shoes and
see what it feels like like if you
started flying a helicopter at 89 but
had the instructor take off so he just
did the cruising around in the air
thoughts um yeah man well first of all
he probably came from the Henny Youngman
era when most of those guys you
know not saying Henny Youngman stole but
like back then like people just did
Street jokes two guys walking to a bar
but uh I actually think it's kind of
cool that in 89 he's 89 years old so he
he got to feel like what it was like to
do stand up he got to feel like what it
was like to be famous he got to feel
what it felt like he got so famous that
there was the backlash he got called a
thief he got the whole [__]
thing look at him his second set's going
to be called his big comeback like
Travolta in [__] uh Pulp Fiction I
think it's wonderful I'm I'm I'm glad
that he did it and I don't have any
problem with him going that's [__]
adorable to see an old guy go up there
at 89 telling old jokes come on you're
not a [__] you got no you have no
blood in hard if you didn't think that
that was adorable all right
corporations uh bill I was doing some
fall Cleanup in my yard because the
maple tree surrounding my house likes to
leave a nice mess during this time where
I where I live the city requires that
you put leaves and grass clippings and
giant paper bags that you can purchase
at various stores when the bags are
filled up we set them out on the curb
and they're picked up during the week
they usually cost around $3 for a bundle
of about five bags one thing I noticed
on these bags which every store you buy
them from their logo Andor slogans are
printed all over the bags like it like
at a home improvement store um when they
are sitting at the curb the store logo
is there for everyone to see who drives
or walks by to see that's brilliant I
realize that because of
this uh I am advertising for that store
for free or actually paying them to
advertise for
them um this is almost the same as if
you bought a car from a dealership and
put an emblem
or a license plate to cover the car with
the dealership oh my God this is killing
my brain I just didn't get enough sleep
um if I could find bags that were blank
I would get those but I have not I
thought to tell you about this because
of your bit about automated cash
registers at the checkout stores and was
wondering what your take was on
something like this love your comedy
thanks go [__]
yourself H you know I don't got a
problem with something like that who
gives a
[__] you know you went in you needed
bags had bags you gave them to them they
put their names on them I don't give a
[__] you
know it's no skin off my [__] back my
thing is working for free um I guess
technically you could be a jerk and be
like you owe me money for advertising
out in front of my house you know start
renting out the space at the end of your
driveway I mean that might be a thing in
the future you know a way to make money
from home like rent out your
mailbox let people put their logo on
it um that'd be hilarious and you have
to start whoring out your kids
listen you call up like Nestle and just
say listen my oldest daughter I'm not
trying to be weird but she's really hot
and everybody wants to [__] her so
they're always driving by the house so I
was thinking what if you guys put like
your little [__] hot cocoa sign on
the side of my mailbox you know so all
those guys you know they'll think that
oh man if I buy this hot cocoa that they
can [__] my daughter and and that
they're not going to do it there there's
no way they're going to do it because
she's already banging one of her
teachers you see what I'm saying Nestle
and they'd be like all right man we'll
[__] do it all right new relationship
hey Bill I need your Insight I just
started hanging out with this girl who's
who's 17 years younger than me yes we
have had
sex but we have not had butt
sex what the
[__] I'm 45 and she's
28 every time I try to come calm her
down for that kind of action her left
leg starts spazzing out and she freezes
up should I dump
her uh or or move
[Laughter]
on ah [__] that guy just mocked the
entire thing that I do at the end of my
podcast and God damn it I loved it I
loved every second of
it um all right well that's the podcast
for this week
um I don't know what to tell you I'm in
New York to do my final
show of the year year year my final Road
gig of the Year all right and I have
already mentally I'm already drinking
eggnog that's how excited I am about
being home for the [__] holidays um
I'm going to be performing at uh Madison
Square Garden believe it or not this
Saturday November
14th and um for for those of you who saw
I I put out a teaser for f is for family
that's coming out on December 18th
everybody and we put out a little teaser
there and uh the rumor
mill is that the trailer is going to be
coming out soon and where you can
actually right now it's just sort of a
little thing just to you know you know
how they do it we get we're [__]
getting you Salva for it um but I'm
really excited about that and check this
[__] out I rented a drum kit
um to be set up at Madison Square Garden
during the day so during the day me and
some of my friends are going to go in
and jam in an empty Madison Square
Garden and
uh it's going to be [__] it's going
to be [__]
ridiculous it's going to be [__]
ridiculous and we're all like [__]
old white guys so we're just geeking out
sending a set list you know we should do
War
Pigs just all this old white guy music
um although that stands the test of time
Black Sabbath does I challenge any
[__] kid today I don't give a [__]
how many mouse heads people have if you
put on Black Sabbath there's no [__]
way you can't appreciate that level of
quality in that music so we're going to
be doing that and uh yes I will
definitely take some video um you know
what's really cool is there was a buddy
of mine forever I've been trying to jam
with them and uh it just never worked
out so I finally called him I said hey
man I'm in New York you want to get
together Saturday and he goes yeah come
on out to my place I moved out to Jersey
I got a rehearsal space and I said nah
man I got a better space and you know
he's proud of his space and I know it's
the [__] so he writes back he's like
what the [__] and then I hit him with it
hey let's go [__] play at uh Madison
Square Garden he [__] freaked [__]
freaked um it's going to be awesome and
for those of you who are already
cringing thinking that I'm easing my way
to at some point playing drums before or
after one of my shows during a live
performance I would never do that to you
okay just know I would never do that
know that I know that I stink all right
I know that I stink I know that this is
just a hobby I know that I will never
make a living okay so [__]
relax all right I'm just a middle-aged
white dude [__] being a geek I'm
allowed to do that all right okay well
that's the podcast for this week it's a
little bit short but uh I'm a little
short on time this week I'll make it up
to you on
Thursday um that's it don't take any
[__] go [__] yourselves and I'll check
in on you on
[Music]
Thursday what's up everybody and welcome
back to the anything better podcast NFL
Edition sponsored by bet MGM and we are
about to get into week number 10 I can't
even believe I'm saying that dude like I
really feel like we just started this
and half the season is over um we got
some fun we got some good games this
week but first of course we got a shout
out the b MGM app guys you guys know how
it works by now if you've been listening
to the show you've been listening to our
picks uh go to bmgm download the app and
use bonus code burr2 200 that's B
rr200 okay couldn't be easier you put
that code in you put as little as $10 in
the account you get up to $200 in bets
regardless of the outcome of your first
wager okay doesn't matter uh bet
responsibly have a great time also they
still have a Survivor uh pool I believe
they still have the Survivor pool you
get some um you get some prizes but it
won't be obviously what the grand prize
is so download the bmgm app today use
bonus code uh bu rr200 that's bur 200
put in 10 bucks and you will get $200 in
bets regardless of the outcome of your
bet now bill
um the giant season's
over uh it's we're two and seven uh I
believe your I mean what's with that
spread this week Jesus Christ oh my God
16 and a half I mean it's over I know
well you got you got a [__] you got
like some guy I don't know third third
string guy playing quarterback at this
point yeah he's a third string
quarterback and I hate to say it but his
name is Tommy DeVito he's an Italian kid
from from Jersey look I'm can't lay off
can't lay off no but he doesn't look
I'll be honest and this is no disrespect
I do love the gold chains that he's got
out but he just doesn't look the part
man you know you know Tommy Tommy D is
gonna be owning a pizzeria dealership
he's gonna have his Giants thing he's
gonna ride that for a while um Patriots
I believe Patriots are also two and
seven who would have thk it Bill who
would have [__] thk it um they're
calling for Bill bellich che's job the
morons if you can [__] believe that
you believe that I mean that's the this
100% can believe it Paul because it's
just what they do to try to get people
stirred up and
um I just I just I was saying on my my
uh Thursday afternoon podcast I was
saying if they fired him that goes up
there with them throwing Oakley out of
the
garden oh you put it there yeah that's
yeah yeah just embarrassing it would
just be embarrassing like uh to do that
I I I I don't even want to think about
it no don't bring it up okay they won't
they I actually think that that's just a
little media talk Bob Bob Craft would
never do that you know Paul you're
really seen but you seen around the
corners Bob Craft would never do that no
way over his dead body Bob Craft what I
said Bob Craft not Robert look at you no
after he got with that scandal with the
massage thing I got call
about after that here after that it's
Bobby to me
Bobby what are you doing what are you
I'm get it we're in Florida we all like
to have a good time but I mean Bobby we
can't have this we can't have it Bill
what do you think about the Dolphins uh
not beating any teams that are basically
have a winning record are the are the
Dolphins for real or
no Paul if you had any sense you'd stay
away from that division yeah the whole
[__] Division I don't even know like
I mean the Jets are the only one that
have a [__]
Excuse excuse jet have a [__] EXC
I've done too many goddamn shows um
Aaron Rogers dude going down that's the
only legitimate excuse the [__] bills
are supposed to be somebody who are they
about Paul they they're [__] coming
and going they're five and four all this
[__] talk all this [__] hype five
and [__] four the dolphins all of a
sudden were looking like they were going
to do something and now what are they I
mean who are they Paul how about the
Ravens dude they look
good uh there's a lot of do they the
Ravens look good but what about also Joe
B the Ravens [__] look good but I bet
I'm against [__] Arizona so I don't
think they look that good
Paul I like Joe burrow in the Bengals
here all right let's we're gonna get
into these picks it's week number 10 we
are collectively above 500 we are always
right there you know what went two and
two last week Paul I'm trying to hang
with you before we get into this before
we get into this
I just want to say something that I
realized I was thinking about this last
night I was like I got to bring this up
on the show a lot of X NFL players are
not good at picking games and I figured
out why like Tiki Barber was on the
radio he's like I'm bad at Tiki Barber's
like nine games under 500 and he's going
I'm bad at this and I figured out why a
lot of players aren't good at it because
they have the mentality of being in that
locker room going yeah we're eight point
underdogs we're going to show you this
week and they carry that they carry that
with them when they see a team they're
like no they're going to come out and
they're going to do it because they
still have the competitive thing and I
think it clouds their minds with picks
that's just my take on it but that's
what I think it is I just don't think
they watch football do they have to for
their job Paul do you watch standup
comedy
no
no I know that is true uh but I would
also think it would make him miss
it I would actually love to see you know
whose paper I'd love to see I'd love to
see Tony Romo pick five games a week
dude that guy would be I think that that
guy would be like tops dude what about
that [__] guy he was in jail he
needed
$10,000 bail and he did like a 10 team
parlay no and he [__] hit it dude he
had all of these teams then out of
nowhere he goes let me get the New York
Liberty he goes yeah the WNBA he picked
the WNBA game ESPN should hire that guy
what and he got bailed because of it
yeah I mean Grant it was one week but it
was [__] a [__] 18 it was
unbelievable dude that's a Hollywood
movie a guy is in jail but his Sports
knowledge gets him
out dude I had a dream last night I was
pitching my next [__]
movie and it was these I was pitching to
these women that were they were living
in in like like the top of a school
[__] house and they had like all the
kids had like painted on the floor and
[__] and I was walking around my bare
feet getting like pain in my I don't
know why I was and they just kept saying
I was trying to picture my idea and they
just kept going that's the stupidest
idea I've ever heard and they were
laughing at me and
uh I was thinking you know what [__] all
you [__] but I didn't say it and I just
walked
out you know when you first started that
I thought you were gonna say I had this
dream I was pitching like you were
pitching in the big game oh no I was
pitching my your next movie which by the
way I can finally [__] tell people
thank the strike's over right can I
finally talk about it thank you everyone
who went to go see old dad's old Paulie
B's in there yeah it was dude it was a
great movie man I got Joey B and I got
all my buddies in there Joey B throwing
hay makers that's a it's a great great
movie Man congratulations on all the
success too it's well deserved I love
how hey Paul it was it was for the
people you know not the [__] lunatics
On The Fringe The Fringe people didn't
all the way to the left all the way to
right they didn't like it guess what
Paul huh guess what that guy getting
that bacon egg and cheese he liked it
there you
go all right here we go I I believe I
have pick number one to I'm the first
pick today because it is a hey heay Paul
after you you know after you week 10
here we
go I'm just gonna kill myself you don't
have the
balls all right you know what are we
gonna do that on
here I I don't know I don't we could I
don't think so no we don't have
to all right um now
listen I have hit the last three
Thursday nights in a row and then I
looked at this Thursday and I go
Panthers
Bears ah and then I looked where it was
and I go Bears at home uh and then I saw
the spread and I said three and a half
I'm not touching it but uhoh something
happened something happened in the
Witching Hour that spread cuz the one
thing I didn't like was the half a point
that's what I was gonna say but that
half a point went bye-bye in the last
little bit and now the Bears are
three-point favorites at home against
the half one win Carolina Panthers they
got a backup quarterback that's doing
pretty good they're tight end Cole KT
who was at my show at zany in Chicago
this year uh he's playing really well
since since I have a three-game win
streak in a row on Thursday and the
spread went from three and a half to
three I am taking the Chicago Bears I'm
gonna Paul's gonna pour himself a glass
of red wine tonight and I'm gonna sit
down and I'm gonna watch the Bears at
Soldier Field win that game by three and
hopefully start my week one and0 for the
fourth week in a row I got the Chicago
Bears tonight baby at home cold weather
Chicago Carolina Panther Panthers don't
survive in the
gold I like that there go all right Paul
my first pick of the week I'm taking the
New England Patriots oh he's taking them
in Germany I'm taking the Patriots and I
I don't have to tell I don't have to
tell you Paul I don't tell anybody why
you don't you don't I'm taking bill bich
and the [__] Patriots all right oh
you know you know why Paul you know why
huh it was out of respect I got to tell
you something dude
dude the Rumblings even the [__]
nerve to even have a reporter say is
Bill bellich and Jeopardy even for that
to be out there in The Ether that has
nothing to do with Bill bich it has to
do with that reporter's marriage bill
it's their own personal [__] Bill
bellich getting one and a half in Europe
oh I love it that's a great pick that's
a great pick I will tell you this though
dude that that [__] team needs to
smarten up and they need to be playing
Bill bich [__] football cuz they're
not that [__] I saw last week the
stupid mental mistakes and the goddamn
penalties I I just I just think Bill is
not having it you text you texted me
Paul hey hey smart that I was just
picturing you going in the locker room
hey hey smart up but you you texted me
something that was really I was like
he's right me and you watch football the
same we really do watching it at your
house that was the best but you said
something to me where when the when the
Patriot guy was yelling on the sideline
and pointing you were like dude this is
not what the Patriots do and you're
right it's like it turn it seems like
they need to Smart no no coach went over
there and told them to shut the [__]
up so that's the thing that kind of
scare me like I think
uh you know they they maybe they're just
frustrated Paul maybe they're just
frustrated I I don't know uh I don't
know what it is but uh dude the memes
with Josh McDaniel there's M there's
memes of like you'll just see like
somebody outside of a gate going like
this and it just says Josh McDaniel's
trying to get back in the
building oh yeah how many times has he
gone away to college only to move back
home Josh you said you were gonna buckle
down you're gonna hit the books what
happened um all right dude this this is
I'm not gonna lie this is a tough week
because all these team these are all
good game dude Lions
Chargers [__] you know I mean I don't
know dudee Saints Vikings both two and a
half a lot of low lines except the
Giants 16 and a half and I hate to say
it but I could see the Giants losing
that game by 30 I'm not touching that
game
um I I I have to do this this to me is a
no-brainer I'm gonna take the Raiders
over the Jets because the Jets can't
score and the Raiders have a new coach
and they're playing for a coach that
they seem to like I saw them smoking
cigars in the locker room laughing I'm a
[__] idiot I I knew you weren't going
to take the Patriots why did I take it
first because I wanted I wanted the
Raiders too I love the Raiders this
week yeah
um I actually really
enjoy
like that whole team dude is just a
[__] different team with that Raiders
that new coach his Vibe is just [__]
different you see you had all the guys
from the taxi Squad standing on the
sideline he goes why they play all week
too it's like oh here we
go here we go they're finally gonna I
don't know I don't know what's going on
but like that their whole vibe [__]
changed they have fun goddamn team to
watch and they are loaded with Talent
Paul dude that kid Max that kid Max
Crosby Dude that [__] that that
defensive end you can say it that
[__] Ginger yeah no no I said no I
heard it I heard it I heard it between
the lines go say
that tattooed Ginger no dude that guy
talk about disruptive dude that guy's a
throwback man that guy's a that guy's
like mad and his nickname is Mad Max I
mean it's incredible Mad Max could have
played in any era he's one of those guys
all right Paul I'm gonna take the Lions
oh my God he's not shying away off of a
by
week taking the Lions you know why Paul
because the Chargers are the Chargers
now usually the lions are the Lions but
I think this this is a new look Lions
team and they win a game like this
they're all rested up I like their coach
better I like the I like the chemistry I
just like the way they [__] you know
I mean it's a [__] three-point spread
Paul that's basically a pickup basically
is all of this [__] this week Paul it's
like basically who do you think's gonna
win the game who do I think
Paul I gotta be honest with you I like
how you're coming out this week you're
coming you're walking up to the line of
scrimmage doing this you're just you
just know you're looking at reads you
just you just you but I might go back
and [__] collapse like Daniel Jones
you never know Paul it can happen or you
might throw a pick six pick six and then
[__] point at the receiver like he
broke off his route and it wasn't my
fault all right man um yeah you know
what you make a good point you make a
good point every once in a while Paul no
it is these are like these these lines
are so close that it's like who's the
better team who's going to win the game
I um Vegas I think the Vegas is going to
win the game I think the Buccaneers I
like the Bucks they're they're minusy
and that NFC South nothing scares me
like the NFC South you got two NFC South
games and Paul's going right in with
them Gators here's a deal I saw the look
on I saw the look on Baker Mayfield's
face when they lost last minute last
time last you know towards the end of
the game and he was devastated they're
at home they're playing the Titans who I
don't know who the Titans are it's a
one-point line and the Bucks are in
Tampa I'm going to take the Bucks minus
one it's basically a pick them all right
I'm GNA say something about Baker
Mayfield you know who he is you know
what his career is reminded me of he's a
modern day Doug
fluty where he just can't get the
[__] respect he keeps going to [__]
franchises and he [__] He's winning
and he's [__] he just doesn't get the
respect he
deserves
um
yeah I mean no like that at all no no no
I saw him I saw him up close last year
uh in game uh week three against the
Giants he can't make all the like I
think his size I think his size is is
part of a little bit of a dis floaty
Doug floaty he can't see over the
line hey can you see the final score
okay uh oh dude I got three favorites
even though they're like pick thems I
don't like that I usually don't do good
when they're all the same what do you
got Phil I like the Cleveland Browns
getting six against the
Ravens oh [__] you can't lay off a Raven
game I never seen anything like
it no I just feel like the Cleveland
Browns are is Deshawn Watson back
whoever the [__] I don't know what's
going on in Cleveland all I know is they
just [__] they play they play well
they're in every game uh they're in
every game and I don't know the I mean
they they you
know yeah I know I like listen I love
the Ravens and you know I love them to
lose to the Chiefs in the [__] AFC
Championship game so little [__] uh
Twinkle Toes I love Patrick Mahomes but
I hate the way he runs there's something
about the way he runs I just cannot get
behind the Kansas City Chiefs his knees
touch he takes Little Steps I don't know
what it is Paul looks like he's running
in his dad's shoes or something it just
just something about it I I can't handle
it um dude that's a great pick Browns
getting six getting six DeShaun Watson
is back and they have a good defense
that's a great pick man hey Paul he's
rested and relaxed if you know what I
mean he's always rested and relaxed um
he's always rested and
relaxed for my fourth and final pick of
week number
10 I am going to take the Pittsburgh
Steelers minus
three against the against a packer team
that is just you know kind of not that
good this year with a new quarterback I
don't know who they are and I know that
Mike Tomlin is good at home and I think
the Steelers need another win so I'm
gonna take the Steelers getting three
and I'm really just basing that off of
the Steelers being home and not on the
road and the line being only a field
goal so there you go and we both love
the city of Pittsburgh we both love the
city of Pittsburgh it's an underrated
City great people great food beautiful
bridges great baseball field good
Coach Joe bartnik from there there you
go
Randy Randy B and and and Bill Crawford
on DV yeah I mean look what's not to
like
Paul uh Mario
lemu the way you're sitting lets me know
you're confident about your fourth and
final pick you look very maybe there's
no more love in this relationship ship
and I don't give a [__] what
[Laughter]
happens you know that guy where his
wife's yelling at him and he doesn't
give a [__]
anymore what you just gonna sit there
what am I allowed to do that you gonna
[__] about that
too she immedately goes out and [__]
her personal trainer um that he's paying
for I'm gonna take I know I swear to god
dude these [__] situation I I really
lucked out in the wife Department d I
really
did um I will say
this I'm taking the Cincinnati Bengals
Paul I like a healthy Joe burrow and I
want to watch a Bengals game because I
really enjoy watching that team play the
[__] solid on both sides of the balls
and every balls both sides of the ball
and [__] everybody's talking about
the Ravens Paul you you better watch out
Paul you better watch come playoff time
Bal you know I think that they got I
think they are they already weathered
their [__]
storm they got the sails up they're
starting to catch a wind and here they
come here they come Paul
dude LSU the Cincinnati Bengals are
going to the AFC Championship game for
sure for sure I don't like how you just
took my [__] pick from me no it's
your pick but I'm saying no wait so you
think it's gonna be cinet versus the
Ravens or you just saying the Ravens are
going to do great in the [__] regular
season no no no I'm talking about how
the Ravens are good now but I think
Cincinnati will probably be back in the
AFC Championship game against the Chiefs
like they were last year that's
literally what I just said did you I
just said you're talking about the
[__] R you're not even listening you
don't even listen to me anymore Paul oh
sorry sorry I thought I just woke up
maybe that's what I thought I said I
love the pick I love the pick what does
Taylor Swift think about it
huh um dude do you know she went around
this [__] business and went straight
to AMC and released her mve mie and made
like a billion dollars I [__] love
this sh I mean I can't listen to music
I'm not going to lie to you okay I don't
have access to crying anymore you know
so her music does nothing for me dude
she's got a couple bangers dude I'm not
gonna lie does she yeah I mean I'm
excited broke up with me I don't give
[__] cuz a [__] strong woman ooy
dooby
do
no dude she's throwing nothing but [__]
right down the [__] pipe to those 15y
old chicks [__] brilliant she really
is she ought to be on the cover of
Forbes
Magazine dude she's 30 years old
crushing
it just
crushing no dude I don't mean writing
hits I'm what she's doing oh in the
business what she's doing to them is
what they're trying to do to us Paul
yeah good for her that dude that deal
they just signed is only for [__]
three years dude and each time they
going to take more of a chunk out of
that [__] AI thing and then
eventually you and I don't exist anymore
but then you know what's great is
they're going to use the AI they're
going to use that that AI [__] to get
rid of each other and then there's just
going to be one person left who makes
all the [__] TV and he just lays in
bed and all the money and he goes give
me a turn me SC s with a [__] gun and
then it's going to all come together get
a robot over here to [__] blow
me
dude they are [__] sociopaths they're
[__] sociopaths and and for all you
regular people out there all you Hamond
eggar AI is not for you it's for them
it's for them they're gonna make us
absolete Paul hey Bill but you want to
know what AI is not gonna be able to
do pick this next [__] game pick
these games like we do come on [__]
AI I got
it AI doesn't see it like I see it
you know what you what that sounds like
what you're going to say as they lead
you out in cuffs and your AI replacement
then he doesn't see it the way I
do ask everybody loves
me nobody had the
Bears no you you can't program some
robot to talk [__] the way I do you know
why it comes from in here you can't you
can't point to your heart your cup it
comes from in here
that's so [__] funny um all right
Bill dude we have been coming so close
to these specials we have been coming so
I mean we got everything early and I
texted bill in the second quarter and I
go dude we just need a Justin Herbert
touchdown throw eckar scored they're
gonna win the game and I'm like it's
done and he doesn't he doesn't do it
because the [__] because uh the Jets
the Jets put no pressure on them because
they can't score score and their defense
was out there whatever anyway all right
guys so this week's Monday night special
the Monday night game is the Denver
Broncos at the Buffalo Bills the bills
are given seven and a half
points um to the
Broncos I don't know Bill what do you
think here I know Russell Wilson's your
guy what do you
think I think hate this game
because I think the Broncos are good
it's a perfect number they're good
enough to hang in there and the bills
just keep tripping over their own
goddamn
feet Josh Allen to throw one for sure no
y
okay you want to do over under and not
touch the
spread what the [__] is going on with uh
the what are the Bills five and four I'm
you know what I'm over those guys I'm
over them I I you know what if I if I
had to pick the game pole with seven and
a half I'd take the
Broncos all right there's something
going on I think like Vegas knows that
they're gonna [__] show up and they
gotta have just enough just enough like
the bills are going to
win but I don't think they're going to
win by seven and up and I wouldn't
surprise me if the [__] Broncos went
because this this dumb [__] always
happens some hapless [__] Team all of
a sudden has a two game win streak in
the middle of
November two to R and then they just
[__] the bed for the rest of the season
you know what I like the way you said
that I think you're right let's go let's
take Paul you're mistaking my sleepiness
for confidence this week just know that
all right Paul you're the one looking
around corners I mean Paul you're
crushing it so hard you're wearing a
jersey of a sport you don't even watch I
mean that's the level that you're
strutting around right
now I didn't want to bring it up I tried
to wait but I just have to be
like you probably think that's an actual
team in the [__] NHL I know it's a
movie I know but look I got my name on
the
back that's [__]
sacrilegious well I know but it was a
gift and I figured hey you know Paul
Newman you know I like Paul Newman
that's the Jersey to
get cuz everybody has like one of the uh
the the Hansen Brothers on the
back Paul num but you don't get the guy
that got did the strip
teas um all right so let's do that we're
going to do Josh Allen's gonna throw one
I love Josh Allen we're gonna take the
points we're gonna take the seven and a
half points and now we need a third what
should be the third should the third be
a Russell Wilson throw and
touchdown I mean we already took the
Broncos Paul how far into this [__]
Underdog [__] are we going to go you
don't think Russell will throw one I
don't know do do we need something St
safe like uh digs to score a touchdown
or something yeah
yeah
yeah no
uh uh Andrew themus says bury the under
but I don't want to lose to that you
know I don't want to lose to that
because if it's a
shootout I I love the under I think it's
going to be a [__] game
[Music]
okay this feel this has Thursday Night
Football written all over it I don't
know why no it's Monday night though I
know but it feels like a Thursday night
like it's gonna be like a Thursday night
game all right you know what we'll do it
I like your instincts today the way you
said yeah because you know I know the
bills need to [__] win and everything
but they can't seem to [__] get out
of their own goddamn way and I think
they're getting a little frustrated in
there the Broncos don't give a
[__] they don't give a [__] they don't
even have their quarterback's phone
number all right so they just die who
gives a [__] now they're playing for
their contracts next year so they don't
get let go bill is not gonna sing the
Monday night special till we hit
one so hey already sang Taylor Swift
this week I can't [__] sing anything
hey hey hey swifties no
disrespect um okay we're gonna seven and
a half points for the Broncos we are
going to take under 47 is right Andrew
under 47 seven and a half for the
Broncos and Josh Allen to throw a
touchdown is that why we don't hit Paul
we always like [__] bet the other
team and then bet the other team's
quarterback to throw a
touchdown so do you want to do it
reverse do you want to do do you want to
do all Broncos and the under you want no
because this is going to be the [__]
week that happens no no we're g yeah hey
Paul you dance with who BR
you well there you have it everybody
those are your picks for week number 10
it's a oh this is a pick them week I
call week number 10 this is a pick them
week this is parody parody week um there
you have to show you how good the NFL
product is Paul it's h I gotta tell you
something man you don't have to Paul
sometimes you can keep your thoughts to
yourself I don't think the uh
the officials man they were really on
point in that Jets game like every time
there was a call and everybody booed
you'd see it You' just see the guy just
pull a jersey and the [__] cornerback
is going yeah I did it I was like all
it's good Flags except you know speaking
of great officials I watched that video
like three times before I went to bed
last night with the Mets
manager comes running out of the Dugout
they got to give us a shot you know that
why don't we get a shot that's [__]
[__] the [__] MLB do [__] to that
guy didn't do [__] [__] to him Tommy
you know why I stand on that Tommy you
know why I stand on that come on walk
with me walk with me that was great
wasn't it listen to me so I can hear
what I'm saying that's my favorite
[Laughter]
line Tommy talk to
me um all right that's it we did it we
got oh sorry did I bring it down I love
that [__] I love that video you got
to give us a shot that [__] he
said that too he went hard he went he
looked right at the rump he went you
[__] and the up didn't throw him
out because of
that I think that kind of knew he was a
[__] Tommy walk with me walk with
me he said I got to listen to what I say
I didn't hear that for listen to me so I
can hear what I'm
saying that's great and then he goes
okay it's good you got it out you got it
out and then he just sort of watches
the the Mets manager walk and then he
just [__] peels off like all right
there we go oh yeah that's one of my
favorite that's probably one of my
favorite ones because it's the most
candid one
ever um rest in peace Bobby Knight even
though if that guy was ever my coach's
son I would
have but your coach's son your son's
coach my son's
coach uh how about that the Knicks
huh last night what happened that kid
came in that webon Yama 74 kid from the
Spurs and um I just like beating Greg
papovich I'm not a Greg papovich
guy
how coaching wise he's great but he's a
dick he's a personal
dick he's treated too many reporters
with disrespect he's treated to
reporters like even Craig Sager he was
short with rest his soul he's just a
he's just an unhappy man I could see it
in his face I know for a fact I know for
fact imagine if you had to [__] take
questions after your standup sets I
would be
nice that's so I
am okay after a tough [__] set paw no
yeah why did you uh why did you feel
like you you know do you feel like maybe
you shouldn't have gone that hard on
your wife on
stage that's different they don't do
that they just no they're talking about
the game they would be talking about
your
uh I know I know but when you see
somebody just go like hey man you guys
shot 34% man any adjustments you're
going to make and he just looks at him
like yeah we're gonna and then it's like
all right dude I don't know I don't like
mean I don't like unhappy people I don't
got time for it
anymore you
know I don't like he never struck me as
unhappy oh dude Bill Parcels used to do
that all the time he [__] loved that
guy he's a dick too he's a
dick yeah I guess I I don't know I I
like when they [__] as opposed just
collectively Sports writers because you
know something and I'll tell you why
Bill bellich don't point at me I'll tell
you why Bill bellich isn't a dick bill
bellich would do it in the funniest way
because he would do it almost like he
was sad he would just go he would just
go yeah no we're gonna we're going to
work on that we're going to just you
know and like you were like okay he's
not going at people
but like Greg papic would be like is
that a good question is that a [__]
is that a it's like he also had [__]
again it does a little bit of ego in
there I there is there is that was my
thing with uh you know rest of his soul
Bobby NY I thought in the end he kind of
felt like he had to ramp it up or
whatever where the earlier on it was
more like authentic Bobby Knight was a
very hard guy for me to
watch in some of those losing their
tempers because I saw a lot of
myself wait wait wait wait without the
Championships but I you know I got a lot
of Bobby night in me Paul just not the
successful
part but you know what I feel like Bill
I feel like if like coaches like Coach K
like Coach K is a guy that I would run
through a wall for because I feel like
that guy wants me maybe I'm wrong but I
feel like that guy would want me to be a
better person in life and it wouldn't be
about him I would have a hard time
running through a wall for Bobby Knight
because Bobby Knight is all about him
and his wins well if you had a hard time
he would have had no problem throwing
you through the [__]
wall I know dude when he grabbed that
kid by the [__] throat man on camera
he grabbed that kid by the [__]
throat dude and obviously he got fired
but like I mean dude what at what point
are you a lunatic like what and I love
how like Isaiah Thomas and people are
like no he's just passionate he's a
great guy it's like he grab the kid by
his [__] throat dude it's
like yeah I I you know what I do yeah I
do like people the amount of people that
grew up in a [__] dysfunctional
family so they relate to it they go like
I'm sorry this is what good coaching is
and everything it's just like you know
he was a great coach and everything but
like there's a lot of that stuff is
uh I was I just got more fascinated like
uh like that guy needed to do mushrooms
like nobody I ever met in my
life and just figure out I you know I
can't imagine what his dad was like no
cuz everybody kind of you know settles
it down or whatever but um I'll tell you
I I I went and I saw him when he was at
Indiana and it was
[__] I mean I was almost not watching
the game sometimes when he was like
yelling on the thing it was [__]
unbelievable like the
level that he was [__] yelling oh my
god
dude it was like he was like with this
[__] I don't want to do it hurt my neck
like it was just it was just
completely [__]
unhinged completely [__] unhinged
like um I can't believe he lived as long
as he did with how much he hated
losing I mean I just like that's why I
think he was so [__] great I mean
that guy [__] hated
losing like I like the level of
frustrated he he would [__] get and
those golf things that he's
doing yeah you know what I that's the
part that made me not then I see like
you know when everyone's standing around
no it's okay you know hey you know doing
trying to keep them like calm and
[__] yeah dude guy [__] guy was uh
you can say whatever you want about him
that dude definitely [__] cared
there's another [__] [__]
shut I
remember I remember I had a keyboarding
class just thinking about coaching I had
a keyboarding class in high school and
the coach's name I mean the the
keyboarding teacher's name who was also
the varsity coach for years was I swear
to God his name was Mr Nick aaker and
everybody called him Mr Nick and uh he
was the nicest man and the calmest man
and amazing and he liked me and we
talked in keyboarding and he goes man he
goes I had to stop coaching the high
school team after a couple decades he
goes he goes I would lose sleep over he
goes I'd be in my home and he goes and I
would lose sleep over it and it's like I
co I'm this year I'm coaching Sophia's
sixth grade team and uh you know last
year I was assistant coach we were nine
and two we got [__] in a championship
but I hold it I remember what happened
and I hold it and I'm going I couldn't
do dude you know all the years I opened
for you doing comedy you know what's
crazy as I realize I haven't opened for
you in six years dude that's how long
it's been since how crazy that is but um
I remember the bad ones and there was
only two that that really stick out with
me not bad the Edmonton one wasn't bad
but that's when I tried that one when
you go try that joke and it was the joke
where I said when you every time you go
to someone's house you see the wedding
picture and the wife looks like she was
training for a decathalon she's all
[__] you see her
jawline and then I said and then it goes
to [__] and I go why don't you just have
halfway just have like halfway so I know
what I'm looking at the next 30 Years
and dude you just heard one voice in a
3,000 cater you just heard one guy go oh
my god dude and I was having a good set
until I did that and I remember that
what are you gonna learn not to listen
to me I remember that one and uh and I
remember uh I tried a new one out count
basy and and I remember I lost him I did
a count basy thing and I lost him but
it's funny I so so the point B Theater
not about count B the count basy theater
I did I did I was having a good good set
and then halfway through I tried
something and I lost him but out of all
the years of opening for you and we've
had some epic ones those two I remember
me making a decision and and and
whatever I don't know if I could be a
coach because I look back at like the
coach of the bills when he's beating the
Bengals in the AFC Championship game
with 13 seconds left and Josh Allen goes
down and scores and they're all on the
thing and there's 13 seconds left and
then they lose that game or the Atlanta
Falcons in the Super Bowl against the
New England Patriots 28-3 with eight
minutes left in the third losing that
game dude I don't know if you come back
from that in life dude in life that's
tough it's like I don't think I'd be a
good
coach because I'd be too busy trying to
psychologically help out the right
fielder just being like listen man it's
I don't know why you're out here if your
dad wanted you come out here but you
know this is all [__] right all
right you're a good dude
what chick do you like go up and talk to
her who gives a [__] if she says no I
would be too busy focusing on rather
than the next five games I'd be focusing
on the right fielders next five years of
his life so he just doesn't get the
sunken
shoulders and just give into [__]
losing like losing becoming a part of
him yeah I well I could see you losing
it on a
ref I could see are they younger me what
up I I couldn't do that cuz I especially
if I was coaching my kids's team I
wouldn't want to embarrass my kid how
impressive is it that Tony dunie never
lost his
[__] I don't think I've ever seen him
lose a [__] when he was on the sidelines
and he won a Super
Bowl dude what does Tony dunie eat all
day celery I've never seen a guy that
old that [__] thin and he's always
been that thin what does
he I'm jealous it's uh he eats the
[__] leaf on top of the Sal too fills
me up yeah he's a thin man what a nice
human being man see a guy like that see
I need a players coach dude for me you
know me dude if I got yelled at and you
were on my team I'd go to your locker
and be like this [__] guy's Ser I'm
not [__] blame [__] this guy oh you
turned the locker room around on me oh
Jesus Christ Paul I'd be the cancer no
um I love Tony dungeon he yelled at me
Bill [__] him he'd be like Paul just
just do good he'll like no no no he he
shouldn't talk to me like that my dad
didn't talk to like that oh I got
another hair Hall of Fame first ballot
guy who Raymond
bour from the Boston
Bruins oh okay I don't know him dude it
looks like he's got a [__] Beaver on
his
head is it real yes
wow here's the thing when you know you
just got [__] great hair you have the
same [__] haircut you had when you
were 20 that you have when you in your
60s I know I know
but I found out D he's got all the hair
he could he could like not not like
[__] you know some people like they
keep it but it gets it gets
thin he has all the
soldiers um Jason lawh head's father
coach remember his hair coach law head
yeah coach he's in the high school
basketball coaching uh Hall of Fame in a
conversation his head of
hair remember oh no he he does no he has
like
listen that 70s hair you know it's like
Curly too but if you get to 70 years old
and you still have you still have
healthy D you it's just in the jeans
it's incredible oh they could reboot Ben
her and if they [__] dyed his hair he
could [__] be in
it uh all right everybody this has been
uh we gave you some overtime we gave you
some we gave you a real podcast there um
this has been episode 10 enjoy the uh
enjoy the week of games don't forget our
Monday night special is the Denver
Broncos getting seven and a half under
47 and Josh Allen to throw a touchdown
um go to the bmgm app download that app
and use our code bonus code bu
rr2 200 bur 200 put in as little as $10
and you get up to $200 in bets
regardless of the outcome of your wager
guys it's easy it's fun bet responsibly
have a great time with it enjoy the
games enjoy the week and uh hey Paul
enjoy your life let's go Bears tonight
baby let's get it four in a row four
Thursdays in a row let's do
it the cold I will see you guys next
week take care all right
byebye